who does the white worm really work for
and who was that literal child who
killed a man with a broadsword house of
the dragon gets even soapier in episode
4. here's what you missed and all that
lather in episode 3 king viserys tried
to make amends by telling his daughter
to choose a husband who makes her happy
episode 4 starts with the end of the
tour he's arranged to introduce her to
more suitors rhaenyra isn't interested
she dreamily fiddles with the necklace
damon gave her and sits cozily next to
sir kristen but around a dozen
candidates line up to state their cases
the first of whom is an old man lord
danderian the donderians are loyal to
the baratheons which might be why
bormund baratheon admonishes rhaenyra
for making a joke about her suitor's
advanced age
that was
unseemly princess next is a boy from
house blackwood he tells his ancient
bloodline and promises that with him her
days will be easy and her knights will
be safe rhaenyra likes the boys bravado
but she's not going to marry him an
unnamed night from rival house bracken
taunts young blackwood and calls him
craven which compels the proud tween to
slay his heckler by cutting him open and
spilling his guts the source material
george r r martin's fire and blood are
lose to a samwell blackwood who lost to
a bracken in a door for a nearest hand
so this scene appears to be the show's
dramatic reinterpretation of the
blackwood slash bracken door with this
black wood named willem per hbo killing
his rival and like his literary
counterpart it's a scene that's ripped
straight from the book damon returns to
king's landing wearing a crown and
calling himself king of the narrow sea
added to the chair
but he offers up the crown to viserys
and swears fealty marking the full
circle of their first estrangement and
reconciliation these brothers have
always had a close but complicated
relationship which comes to light
drawing what else a fisa king throws in
his prodigal brother's honor no no no no
i will not revisit this debate you are
always mother's favorite the kings in a
jolly mood made jollia by wine but there
are decades worth of sibling rivalry in
his reminiscing he says that their
mother princess alyssa had no regard for
custom or traditional rules and that he
beceres was no great warrior in the
source material it's true that alyssa
favored damon and took him dragon riding
with her from the time of his infancy
like her granddaughter rhaenyra she was
a hot-blooded and non-traditional woman
who loved dragons sometimes dressed in
boy's clothing and preferred swordplay
and taverns to more ladylike endeavors
she would have been proud of the dragon
rider and fighter that damon became and
it's very likely that viserys feels
self-conscious about the fact that he's
a targaryen without a dragon or real
combat experience however in fire and
blood princess alyssa dies in childbirth
and both vasaris and damon would have
been too young to remember much of their
time with her so their conversation is
either a change from the book or the
king's drunken rambling about a woman he
barely remembers
fire and blood is an in-universe history
text with multiple sources including
clergyman septoneustus and the three
foot tall court four named mushroom the
events of the fourth episode of house of
the dragon are a turning point in fire
and blood but when it comes to rhaenyra
and daemon the book sources diverge
according to septon eustace the princess
had an enormous crush on her uncle and
was easily seduced when a guard caught
them rhaenyra told the king she was in
love with his brother and begged to
marry him wish the king forbade as damon
already had a wife mushroom's version of
events is more depraved he claimed damon
took rhaenyra to the pleasure houses and
fooled around with her butts did not
deflower her so that she could learn how
to be good in bed for sir kristin house
of the dragon blends the two accounts
daemon sneaks rhaenyra out in paige's
clothing as he does in the book and he
takes her to the street of silk after
their brief encounter in the brothel
damon runs away andre nera uses her
newfound carnal knowledge to bed her
white knight but when rhaenyra and damon
are accused they tell different stories
she assures queen allison that a virtue
is intact at least when it comes to
daemon while damon doesn't deny anything
and tells his brother he wants to wed
his niece in keeping with the spirit of
the book viserys tells his daughter that
the truth of what occurred doesn't
matter only the perception which is a
shrewd way to read history including the
fictional history of westeros
otto hightower enters the king's bed
chamber at the crack of dawn with
discomforting news he tells the series
that rhaenyra was spied at the pleasure
house was damon and the two were
coupling as he puts it becerris finally
has the sense to question otto's motives
and loyalty to the crown but the hand in
sister source has yet to lead him astray
that source is the white worm who uses a
boy spy and messenger to practice her
trade the white worm is revealed to be
massaria when that same boy comes to her
later with payment as she tends to a
hunger over daemon she tells him she's
got a now to the skin trade since it
could only take her so far does damon
know that she's actually gotten into the
business of selling secrets it's
possible she's still on his side since
getting caught might have been damon's
plan all along if he marries his niece
rhaenyra as he proposes once for sarah
sings he's defiled her he'll be closer
to the throne than he ever could be
otherwise you targaryens do have queer
customs
osiris decides to move forward with
rhaenyra as his heir and he decides to
force her to move forward with the
politically advantageous marriage to
lane or velaryon but it's not just the
current divisions within the kingdom
that worry the king he puts stuck in
dreams and none more so than aegon's
berseras holds the cat's poor dagger to
a flame and tells his daughter that the
dagger belonged to aegon the conqueror
saying that a pyromancer hid his song in
the steel rhaenyra picks it up and reads
the blade's inscription from my blood
come the prince that was promised and
his will be the song of ice and fire
osiris has entrusted her with the
knowledge of aegon's dream she knows
that some threat lies in weight in the
north but he also means that it may be
her responsibility to give birth to the
prince that was promised or to continue
a family line from which that prince
will come her father the king needs her
not just to marry for peace in their own
time but to produce a strong valyrian
dragon riding heir who could be the
savior of the world when the maester
leaves rhaenyra the abort of fashion tea
it's not just an implication that he's
not sure whether to believe her he wants
to preserve her womb for the fourth old
prince
[Music]